we of course have to hit wonder woman
and with that one i am wondering
maybe the decision of committing to a
big franchise like that because you've
done a whole bunch of
big big films out there but committing
to something like the dc
franchise is a different kind of
commitment so when you're considering
whether or not to take a role in a film
series like that is there any new
element of the decision-making process
that might not have been there before
patty jenkins the director her
enthusiasm on the phone when she called
me because i was shooting house cards at
the time she called she's like do you
want to play one of the greatest warrior
women
of the amazon nation i was like of
course
it was it was a no-brainer i was like
that's going to be a hoot
and we got to get in the best shape of
our lives
training for that movie at you know 50
years old i was like
i'm into that let's go for it i just i i
adore her
and and i loved the movies both movies
messages
are really about justice and equality
and love and i don't know
i'm a sucker for that stuff
understandable
i don't know if this is something you're
even interested in but let's say you got
the opportunity to
direct a big franchise film like a
wonder woman what is something
that patty did on set as far as you know
being there to support you
creating a great atmosphere on set that
you would want to bring to your own
blockbuster film
again it's it's her passion and her
enthusiasm she's so
quick and so bright and she really
pushed to have her movie you know
because that's that's a big
production stew you know that's a big
pot
a lot of people a lot of opinions and
um a lot of
directions you know this is the movie
that we should make this is the movie we
should release
all those and she really persevered
and she would they were able to make her
her movie
i do like hearing that so just maybe to
get into more specifics there is there
anything
that you saw patty do or decision that
she made
that showed to you that she was holding
tight to her vision
even if uh someone around you guys
suggested otherwise
just she's she's like um
she's the energizer bunny she just you
know she's gonna
she's going to get what she wants and
she doesn't have to be mean about it
she's just very
she's very ambitious and i
really respect that strength
you